even villains you know need a little bit
of joy and company in their life
everyone just wants love really
I love Disney so much
I really do I like Disney movies I like
the old Disney movies sure there's so
many great villains out there they're
probably like the most fun parts to play
I want to be too far I want to get you
far because his figure is very slender
and snake-like I feel like in all of the
Disney movies there's always this moment
between right and wrong and you always
think you'll do the right thing but I
think most of us would actually end up
doing the wrong thing I'm gonna take a
quiz I'm gonna take a freak quiz number
one what is your greatest quality being
manipulative
being sinister being vain being sadistic
being ambitious I'm gonna say being
ambitious I would say for myself being
ambitious I'm also gonna say ambitious I
want to say being ambitious all right
good job
being ambitious what is your ideal layer
a castle deep in the woods a castle atop
a mountain a palace in a kingdom out in
the wild in a cave deep in the [ __ ]
woods dug like a castle in the woods
sounds like looking for like amazing
castle on a mountain love mountains high
and above everyone else and far away and
hard to get to my ideal hair don't want
to pass in the kingdom or do I want to
pass on a mount and you know what scares
me because no one could do scream now
and I wanted a castle on top of a
mountain I'm gonna say a castle on a
mountain because if you're a castle deep
in the woods people are gonna stumble
upon your castle and be like what's
going on in here and you're like oh in
prison you know how would you describe
your style elegant but powerful
mysterious beautiful and regal minimal
but still intimidating glamorous I'd
pick minimal but still intimidating okay
I'm gonna say minimal but still
intimidating sometimes I'll just wear
like a simple sweater but then I turned
to the side and I'm like booty
you know boney I would say it was
serious because I've been looking for a
cowl-neck sweater for about three years
now so you've been looking for it for
three years yeah I want a good one
look my grandfather he was looking for a
good soup spoon for years and he finally
bought one well he asked if I went from
Cracker Barrel and they just gave it to
him now he keeps it in his pocket but
never know what you're gonna get soup
and though I'm gonna go elegant but
powerful because I'm attracted to those
words how do you prefer your sidekick
wisecracking cunning
insane sly I don't like sidekicks I want
to say wisecracking because Iago
but the seclusion is kind of the reason
why I have a lair deep in the woods
no psychics I don't like sidekicks I'm
on my own no I need a sidekick
wisecracking not like my sidekick to be
wisecracking my sidekick will probably
be cunning because wow what a dangerous
combination yeah okay what is the best
motivation to be evil for revenge to
obtain power out of jealousy out of
pride or Speights revenge it's all about
the revenge revenge
yeah it's easily easily revenge
everything I've ever done in my life
ever has been because someone didn't
love me revenge is about justice
it is revenge okay what is the best
accessory a villain can have a staff a
cauldron a crystal ball long robes or
none long robes Doug I gotta have gotta
have those long robes fast easy when
you're at a wedding you see the bride
walk down the aisle and she's got that
long
Whizzer caught a train long train behind
her and he just like man that's the dope
is part of the dress I want a robe
that's as long as a wedding gown
straight just what do it who knows
what's gonna come out of that back
flames
ice snakes who knows it's a skin stuff
for me yeah I'm gonna say staff because
it's looking subtle weapon but also you
could be like Lyman or lady here Wow oh
girl Gandalf like you know I figure
called room because potions are so much
fun yeah a lot of good cocktails ahead
which of these powers is the best
ability to hypnotize people the ability
to metamorphose being able to put curses
on people being able to use magic spells
just plain old brute strength
[Music]
I think magic spells coming to get
Maleficent or whatever she is yeah
you're gonna get Melissa I'm gonna go
with the ability to metamorphose even
though I don't completely understand
what that word means but I think if it's
like you can change your appearance mmm
that's one of the scariest things in a
villain I could turn into somebody that
you love and I can really focus um stuff
I don't like that this is getting really
dark I'm gonna say just plain old brute
strength I'm gonna sync magic spells
because as somebody who is a bruja
herself which is a witch no I mean
practicing okay but a good bruja okay
okay it's versatile you can make any
sorts of spells to make people love you
which I have not tried to do yeah what
are your power colors orange and brown
black and red red and purple purple and
black black and gray black and red
it looks very sinister I don't know
these are all evil I'm going purple in
black purple black I lost purple and I
love black I would have picked purple
black and blue but I'll just stick with
purple and black you're gonna get
Melissa I'm gonna say
purple nice what is your weapon of
choice a staff a henchman no need to get
my hands dirty magic of course teeth and
claws transformation I would do magic of
course magic of course yeah Joey every
villain needs a henchman people to die
first so you have a sidekick and a
henchman what are you doin a staff and
the ability to metamorphose I'm
indestructible I think I would do
transformation which of these do you
hate the most
true love beauty family not being
included those with more power not being
included those with more power I think
that being included say not being
included I'm not gonna have anyone out
villain me mmm and every movie the
villain always loses my movie will be
the one where the villain wins you know
I be included sure yeah you can come I
will have more power than you what is
the best way to get back at your enemies
embarrassing them put a curse on them
emotionally manipulating them
emotionally manipulating one of their
loved ones or killing them they got a
die doc
I think embarrass them hopefully then
they'll turn it into more they'll go
down the comedy route instead of the
revenge route yeah what'd you think
about the person who's done you to hurt
you got my dirty done you wrong I used
to go with embarrassing them okay
embarrassing them yeah I would just
embarrass them I guess nothing got it go
cuz we're curse them you want them to
suffer I don't want them in my life at
all no but cursing them could be funny
it could be suffering but not bad it's
sort of like every time you order
chicken fingers you're given sliced
Apple it's like that every time you go
to have some sort of like delicious
treat you get confused ed your biggest
fear is sword through the heart falling
off a cliff having a boulder fall on you
being in trapped in a small space being
struck by the lightning the Evil Queen
got struck by lightning and then the
boulder fell on her right so she does
look at double whammy so I'm gonna say
Boulder falling on me sort through the
heart because that is very painful and
then you starts like purple blood and
all that stuff and I said I don't like
that and trapped in a small space
everything else will kill me relatively
quickly mine's probably being entrapped
in a small space dammit I'm gonna get
Jafar yeah
you're the evil queen nice okay that's
the one who's the fairest of them all
right you just need to be prettiest
you're mad if you're not the prettiest
no that's okay yep
Who am I you're I know yeah there it is
purple her landlord got me yeah well at
least you got to turn into a dragon
[Music]
really oh hell yeah fire didn't we fire
green fire
the best day my life Maya
[Music]
I will admit I am a jealous person and
sometimes I'm like mirror what the hell
yeah like what's going on why is she
getting up more than me
wheeze witch Maleficent are we dealing
with here the angelina jolie one or the
cartoon the OG okay well either way well
since a bad ass [ __ ]
Disney villain had a reason yeah got a
pretty good reason to be mad and said
they have problems they have stuff that
they're working evil also it was
different than they didn't have access
to like mental healthcare that we do now
so they didn't know what to do with it
yeah they didn't have like iPods see
those are just people like who needed
help
iPods can you do like on an angle app
[Music]